de la fumée s'échappe encore des débris
cet immeuble d'habitation d'une
quinzaine d'étages a été éventrée la
veille par une frappe russe
il y a des avions des fusées ici tout le
temps tous les jours comme Nadia ils
sont près de 2300 à être restés dans la
ville d'avesca qui comptait 30 000
habitants avant la guerre situé à 60 km
au sud de Dark mode et à la périphérie
de doniesk ville occupé par les
séparatistes pour russes depuis 2014
Moscou tente à tout prix de s'en emparer
ces derniers jours les bombardements
s'intensifient une dizaine de missiles
s'abattent quotidiennement sur la ville
mais pour les habitants sur place elle
n'est pas prête de tomber
les Russes essaient de nous encercler
petit à petit
sur la ligne de front depuis 2014 c'est
une ligne de fortification très robuste
tout en béton armé avec des bunkers
c'est une vraie forteresse c'est mieux
protéger que barkout a surtout des
tranchées ici on a des bunkers
les évacuations de civils continuent 150
personnes ont pu quitter la ville ces
trois dernières semaines d'autres comme
cet habitant ont décidé de rester et de
survivre comme il le peuvent au milieu
des ruines